-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope
you're doing well tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
we are going to get to the news.
After New York Congressman
George Santos
was expelled from the House
of Representatives last week,
Santos told reporters, quote,
"to hell with this place"
and left in a black SUV.
Ah, yes, the official exit
of hot messes everywhere.
That's the same way Andy Dick
left every restaurant
for six years.
That's right. George Santos was
expelled last week
from the House, and the sign
in front of his office
was taken down.
No clue why it was up
in the first place.
In her new book, former
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
writes that Republican
Representative Mark Green
referred to former
President Trump as, quote,
"Orange Jesus." What?
Orange Jesus?
The only way Trump is like
Jesus
is that both got other people
to write their books for them.
Cheney also writes
that former President Trump
was so depressed
after losing the 2020 election
that he stopped eating,
unless you count the thousands
and thousands
of classified documents.
"I'll be --
I'll be right there."
"We have a warrant."
"Oh, then come in."
President Biden over
the weekend
hosted Kennedy Center honorees,
including actor Billy Crystal
and Queen Latifah.
Hey, get out of there!
Damn it, George!
A deer in Maine recently crashed
through the window of a TJ Maxx.
But the manager
was actually happy
because now there's a reason
the store looks like that.
The streaming service
Spotify announced today
that it will cut 1,500 jobs.
Even worse, they notified
the employees
through their Spotify Wrapped.
And finally, the University
of Minnesota has announced
it will launch a new cannabis
research center or,
as they're more
commonly known,
dorms.
That was a monologue, everybody.
We're up and running.